I'm confident that Vladimir Putin was
counting on being able to divide NATO
to be able to separate the Eastern flank
from the West be able to separate the
Nations based on past histories
but he hadn't been able to do it
we've all stayed together
and uh and so I just think it's so
important
that we pulled in the United States
keep in lockstep and how we're
perceiving
and after meeting President Biden a
Ukraine's foreign minister told
reporters his countries received
additional security pledges from the U.S
Ukrainian stamina and Western weapons
mostly American weapons is the recipe
for Success on the Battleground
today we did receive additional promises
from the United States on how our
defense cooperation will evolve we are
grateful to the United States on this
military military thing
our security and defense editor Deborah
Haynes has the latest from those talks
in Warsaw
we're there is where the
the bilateral meeting between Joe Biden
and his polish counterpart president
duder took place and we've just heard
those remarks from the two of them I
think the key point to flag and
President Biden made it at the beginning
and the end of his remarks was that
whole idea of Article 5 being sacred now
Article 5 is the shorthand way that NATO
allies talk about the founding principle
the fundamental principle of the NATO
alliance a 30-member transatlantic
defense Community which means there's an
attack on one member state would then
trigger the response of all 30 allies
together to retaliate and that is a
protection that all 30 member states
enjoy and one that Ukraine which is not
part of the NATO alliance doesn't have
and it was actually Ukraine's desire to
join NATO that was one of the red lines
to President Putin that prompted him to
then invade Ukraine even though he talks
about other issues to justify it using
fake claims about the threat he believes
Ukraine Ukraine's government poses but
for Poland which borders Ukraine and
you've got this sense from what the
Polish president was saying the crisis
here is so close it's already affecting
this country because of the wave upon
wave of Ukrainian refugees fleeing here
but at the same time any mistake perhaps
from the missiles and Military attacks
that Russia is launching against Ukraine
were they to stray across the border
into Poland then that would trigger
potentially
drawing Poland into the war and and
blowing it up into a war that involves
NATO because like I said Article 5 is
this fundamental principle a sacred one
in President Biden's words and it's a
it's really interesting as well to note
that the U.S president this U.S
president is takes so much care to
repeat to his NATO allies that the U.S
is absolutely behind that principle of
Article 5 because it's something that
his predecessor just didn't do Donald
Trump you'll know had a very uneasy
relationship with NATO and that article
5
principle was under him something that
people would often talk about with
concern not now under President Biden
and that was clearly why he keeps on
repeating it